welcome to the presentation on limits
let's get started with some well first
an explanation before i do any problems
so let's say i had um let me make sure i
have the right color and my pen works
okay let's say i had
the limit
and i'll explain what a limit is in a
second but the way you write it is here
you say what's the limit oh with my
color it's i'm in the wrong
okay i need to use a pen i'm in yellow
okay
the limit
as x
approaches 2
of
x squared
of x squared
now all this is saying is what value
does this expression x squared approach
as x approaches 2
well i this is pretty easy if we look at
it let me draw draw a graph
i'll stay in this yellow color
so let me draw
x squared x squared looks something like
let me
use a different color
let's x squared look something like this
right
squared and when x is equal to 2
when x is equal to 2
y or the expression because we don't say
what this is equal to just the
expression x squared is equal to 4 right
it's like that right so a limit is
saying as x approaches 2 and as x
approaches 2 from both sides from the
from numbers less than 2 and from
numbers right than 2 what does the
expression approach so
and and you might i think already see
where this is going and be wondering why
we're even going to the trouble of
learning this new concept because it
seems pretty obvious but as x
as we get to x is closer and closer to 2
from this direction and as we get to x
is closer and closer to this direction
what does this expression equal well it
essentially equals four right the
expression is equal to
or the way i think about is as you move
on the curve
closer and closer to
the expression's value what does the
expression equal in this case it equals
four so you're probably saying sal
this seems like a useless concept
because i could have just stuck two in
there and i know that you know if this
is say this is f of x that if f of x is
equal to x squared that f of 2 is equal
to 4 and that would have been a
no-brainer
well let me let me
maybe give you one wrinkle on that and
and hopefully now you'll start to see
what the use of a limit is let me define
let me say
f of x
is equal to
x squared
when
if
x does not equal 2
and let's say it equals
when
x equals 2
interesting so it's a slight variation
on on this
expression right here so this is our new
f of x so let me ask you a question what
is
actually my pen still works what is the
limit
i used cursive this time what is the
limit as
as x
that's an x as x approaches 2
of f of x
that's an x that says x approaches do
it's just like that i just
i don't know for some reason my brain
isn't working functionally
okay so let me let me let me graph this
now
so
as an equally neat looking graph that's
the one i just
drew let me draw so now it's almost the
same as this curve except something
interesting happens at x equals 2.
so it's it's just like this it's like an
x squared curve like
like that
but at x equals two
and f of x equals four we draw a little
hole
we draw a whole right because it's not
defined at x equals two this is x equals
two
this is two
this is four this is the f of x axis of
course and when x is equal to 2 let's
say this is 3.
when x is equal to 2 f of x is equal to
3. this is actually right below this i
should it doesn't look completely right
below it but i think you you got to get
the picture see this graph is x squared
it's exactly x squared
until we get to x equals two at x equals
two we have a graph
we got a graph we have a gap in the
graph which maybe could be called a
graph but we have a gap in the graph and
then we keep and then after uh x equals
two we keep moving on and that that gap
and that gap is defined right here what
happens when x equals two well then f of
x is equal to three so this graph kind
of goes it's just like x squared
and then it's at but instead of f of two
being four
f of two drops down to three but then we
keep on going so going back to the limit
problem what is the limit as x
approaches 2 now well let's think about
the same thing we're going to go this is
how i visualize it i go along the curve
so let me pick a different color
so as x approaches 2 from this side from
the left hand side or from numbers less
than 2
f of x
is approaching
values
approaching 4 right f of x is
approaching
4 as you go as x approaches 2 right i
think you see that if you just follow
along the curve
as you approach f of 2
you get closer and closer to 4.
similarly
as you go from the right hand side
and make sure my thing's still working
you go along the curve
and
f of x is also
slowly approaching four
so as you can see as as we go closer and
closer and closer to x equals 2
f of whatever number that is approaches
4 right so in this case the limit as x
approaches 2 is also equal to
is equal to
4. well this is interesting because in
this case
the limit
as x approaches 2
of f of x
does not equal f of 2.
right now normally this would be on this
line this isn't it in this case the
limit as you approach the expression is
equal to evaluating the expression at
that value in this case the limit isn't
so this is i think now you're starting
to see why the limit is a slightly
different concept than just evaluating
the function at that point because you
have functions where for whatever reason
at a certain point
either the function might not be defined
or the function kind of
jumps up or down but as you approach
that point you still approach a value
different than the function at that
point
now that's my introduction i think this
will give you an intuition for what a
limit is in another presentation i'll
give you the more formal mathematical
you know the delta epsilon a definition
of a limit and actually in the very next
module i'm not going to do a bunch of
problems involving the limit i think as
you do more and more problems you'll get
more and more of an intuition as to what
a limit is and then as we go into uh
derivatives and integrals you'll
actually understand why why people
probably even invented limits to begin
with
we'll see you in the next presentation